[Musique]
oui sus au froid et il faut l'affronter
monsieur qui a chaud qui a passé une
nuit agitée pour se réchauffer semble
d'ailleurs bien décidés mais se raser de
bon matin que de problèmes
et puis ces radiateurs ce chauffage
pauvre monsieur qui est chaud et il
n'est pas le seul d'ailleurs
alors vive les cheminées de nos grands
mères
reste à savoir comment allumer le feu et
surtout à trouver le combustible
et on ne recule devant rien
mais laissons là monsieur qui a chaud
pensons à ceux qui ont encore plus froid
dehors sous la neige et la glace fondue
cet après midi certains ont été forcés
de travailler
ainsi cette vieille dame a vendu aux
passants du mimosa la fleur du soleil et
des roses
vous êtes là depuis que leur mère parce
qu'on ne pouvait pas des baleineaux
fleurs et j'ai beaucoup de gens que je
déplorais a coûté pour beaucoup on ne
peut pas les sortir mais enfin il faut
travailler pour même n'est pas resté
dans la rue à rester chez soi vous
vendez du mimosa
il vient d'où nani de nous répond me à
sa vie en parler vous nous forcez pas de
gants jamais mais peu dangereux
pas du tout et vous n'avez pas manger je
prends lampe en forme des groupes il est
plus de trois heures de l'après midi
c'est pas rigolo de travailler comme ça
dans la rue et après votre bord qu'est
ce que vous allez faire un vin je vais
revenir je vais à joal temps chez lenovo
ravitailler un peu et après je retourne
le vendre
et demain pour commencer et recommencer
si jal pas de trop et bien ce que ton
que chacun puisse se faire un peu de
mimosa pour les fêtes de fin d'année en
espérant beaucoup et qu'on travaille en
type parce que nous avons passé en cinq
duels
notre métier doit être pénible monsieur
oui on peut travailler depuis quelle
heure depuis 4h30 que je parle de chez
moi et vous jamais à quelle heure à 5h30
les yeux le travail consiste en coin
enlevez les papiers les ordures d'abord
evry lors du matin jusqu'à 9h et puis
après en bas on fait le balayage et
surtout avec le vent sans paul vous
comprenez alors on obligé de courir par
les papiers partout et ce qui est
beaucoup plus de travail en ce moment
par weepu plus parce que je pensais que
l'on ne peut pas couler l'eau alors on
est obligé de travailler de plus quoi il
est plutôt oui il est pas tombé beaucoup
de neige encore non pas encore
heureusement et si ça tombe un peu plus
alors là on travaille fêté dimanche vous
avez des collègues qui sont spécialisés
dans la lutte contre la neige a oui la
nuit alors en quoi ça consiste
bah ça les a à m faire les eaux salées
tout ça c'est dit monsieur c'est facile
de prendre l'autobus ont qu'en ce moment
et bien sûr remise de prix vous avez une
plateforme découverte vous aimez moi
j'ai pas mangé le pain selon moi c'est
pas plus pénibles qui l'humilie aussi
bien sur pied ferme
monsieur le post a jugé que ce que vous
en pensez mais moi je trouve qu'il fait
mais hier matin chez - from sable
préféré paul métro non je préfère encore
prendre l'air ok c'est difficile de
circuler pour ton froid pareil et bien
sûr ce rassemblement a créé le
brouillard d'eau mais à neige et vous
croyez pas que les automobilistes qui
préfère prendre le métro
mais c'est bien mieux pourquoi j'irais
bien sûr ça aurait mieux couverts vous
partez 1
et oui mais on part mais il ya une
voiture mais si vous pensez tout de
suite
bonjour la pointe d'une journée s'il
vous plaît donc n'est pas chaud de stora
non moussier mais quel âge vous avez
main combien 80 des gens mais vous vous
avez encore des journaux mais oui
monsieur mais vous gagnez beaucoup
vendre des journaux comme ça à petit et
combien vous voyez par jour est enfin
400 francs uniquement pour vous toutes
et refroidir comme ça dans la rue mais
oui mais à ma faim au délit vous ayez me
vous réchauffer pas vous êtes appuyé du
chaudron car oui monsieur
message de thé blessé au pied levé des
missions plus de st oui alors fait pas
mouche chaussée et vous pouvez pas faire
un autre métier de soins parce que tu
veux vu les malaises mais je suis
cuisinier de métier et je suis ronde
j'aime bien les bonnes choses mais pas
la neige du froid et non au corps à
corps qu'est la vie voilà
non merci
[Musique]